[Musique]
il y a tout le monde qui veut
deveniriste maintenant parce que m très
no tu es sur scène tu fais tu fais venir
beaucoup de gens des gens civilisés des
gens corrects donc pour rire donc
vraiment il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui
cour pour être
humoriste
[Musique]
au Sénégal ici c'est un peu compliqué
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de tabou on
touche pas la religion on touche pas le
sexe il y a pas mal de sujet tabou quoi
donc il faut bien bien bien bien
réfléchir pour pour pouvoir arriver à
faire lire à faire rire les gens sans
leur vexer quoi
parce que le Sénégalais est trop facile
facile à
[Musique]
vexer non même si tu fais tu te
dépigmentes la peau tu vas aboutir qu'à
un résultat bicolore pourquoi le piment
rouge est rouge parce que on l'a composé
de s humain au début moi on on m taxé de
lososeer je disais que ce garslà il est
marié récemment et Il est sur internet a
fait le clown tu vois donc c'est un
métier euh c'est un métier je peux dire
qui n'est pas respecté au Sénégal mais
c'est à c'est à l'himouris même de de
s'imposer et et et d'essayer de réussir
dans les
métiers wou aujourhui beaucoup au elle
m'a lancé le défi elle m'a dit qu écrit
sur le
mur je sais pas s'il y en a ici mais de
l'endroit o je viens en France on
prévient les touristes qu' a les volur
dans les
Mét
[Applaudissements]
encore